for the last two weeks more than a
hundred and forty migrants have been
aboard the proact Eva open arms looking
for a place to dock safely they were
rescued by the Spanish NGO vessel off
the Libyan coast as weather conditions
worsened at sea four on board including
two infants were allowed off the vessel
taken by the Italian Coast Guard for
urgent medical attention
picked up so a lot of people were
seasick this is already on top of
suffering this had to do Big C and their
flimsy boats and also on top of the the
problems they've had coming from trivia
where they faced arbitrary detention
they faced torture rape and murder is a
common thing in the middle of this a
political storm swirling around the
interior minister Matteo salvini leader
of the far-right League party and one of
Italy's two deputy Prime Minister's he
is also the face of Italy's
anti-immigration policies but as well as
supporters for his anti migrants stance
he also has his detractors salvini had
issued a decree keeping the vessel out
of Italian waters but was overruled by
an Italian judge as well as the
country's defense minister who is a
member of the populist five star
movement former coalition partners with
the league at first five-star tempered
its criticism towards the league's
policies but that has changed and it is
open warfare between the two parties
there's was always an uncomfortable
pairing over many issues including
immigration not that it matters in
public to salvini
who doubled down on his decision to
issue the decree meet confess or cool
people 60 million Italians pay me a
salary for this obsession not to be a
tender soul but to protect our borders
for security for dignity and for the
honour of my country if I am being a
good Minister of the Interior then so be
it if I am not good and some are prefers
to go back to the past by choosing
someone from the Democratic Party just
say it
and caught up in the middle those still
aboard
the rescue vessel at sea waiting to head
to a new life in Europe
sonica ago al-jazeera